Donald Trump has said repeatedly
repeatedly that he did nothing wrong do
you believe that
well here's what I believe we live in an
America where if you're the Democratic
candidate for president Hillary Clinton
Secretary of State you can set up a
private server in your basement to
conduct government business and when an
investigation is had about your activity
no let me finish
but you didn't answer the question it
was ridiculous well yeah I'm trying to
answer the question from a republican
point of view that may not be acceptable
on this show well it's not an answer
right do you agree Trump did nothing
wrong
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton wait I'd like you to answer the
I am answering the question from a
republican point of view whoa okay